>>> IT SOUNDS LIKE THE PLOT OF A
SCI-FI THRILLER, SAVING THE
WORLD FROM AN ASTROID HURDLING
TOWARD HURT.
BUT DON'T WORRY, IT IS ONLY A
PRACTICE RUN.
NASA WILL TEST WHETHER IT CAN
KNOCK AN ASTROID OFF ITS PATH.
IT WILL CRASH A SPACECRAFT INTO
IT.
AND I WANT TO BRING IN KNEEL GEE
DE GRASSE
[ KNEEL DGRASS TYSON.
THEY HAVE TRIED IT IN THE MOVIES
AND I THINK THERE WAS A PART OF
DON'T LOOK UP, I BELIEVE THAT IS
ANOTHER CULTURAL REFERENCE WE
COULD MAKE HERE.
IS THIS A GOOD IDEA?
>> AFTER I SAW DON'T LOOK UP, I
WAS CERTAINLY IT WAS A DOCUMENT
IT AREA BASED ON MY LIFE
EXPERIENCE.
SO I THINK THAT IT IS ONE OF THE
BEST IDEAS EVER PUT INTO A SPACE
MISSION BECAUSE BUILT INTO IT IS
THE FUTURE SECURITY AND SAFETY
OF OUR SPECIES.
AND OF COURSE OTHER SPECIES ON
EARTH.
SO THE DAY AN ASTROID IS
DISCOVERED HEADED TOWARDS US,
YOU WANT TO KNOW THAT SOMEBODY
HAS TESTED WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO
DEFLECT IT.
AND BY THE WAY, ALL THIS TALK
ABOUT LET'S BLOW IT OUT OF THE
SKY, YOU KNOW, IN AMERICA WE'RE
GOOD AT BLOWING STUFF UP AND
LESS GOOD AT KNOWING WHERE THE
PIECES GO AFTERWARDS.
SO DEFLECTING AN ASTROID IS BY
FAR THE MOST INTELLIGENT THING
DO.
SO THIS IS A TEST FOR THAT.
>> DO WE HAVE ANYTHING THAT IS
BIG ENOUGH TO BLOW UP AN
ASTROID?
I HOPE MAYBE CRASHING SOMETHING
INTO IT MIGHT BE THE MOST
FEASIBLE ALTERNATIVE.
BUT HOW REAL OF A THREAT IS
THIS?
>> LET ME MAKE IT CLEAR, THIS IS
CALLED THE DOUBLE ASTROID
REDIRECT TEST.
AND WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE, BEING
NASA, WE THE UNITED STATES,
IS -- THERE IS AN ASTROID THAT
HAS A LITTLE ASTROID MOON, I
GUESS WE CALL IT A MOONLET.
AND IT IS ORBITING THAT ASTROID.
AND ALL WE'RE GOING TO DO IS
CRASH INTO THE MOONLET AND SEE
WHAT IT DOES TO THE ORBIT OF
THAT MOONLET AROUND THIS
ASTROID.
SO IT IS NOT LIKE THIS IS HEADED
TOWARDS US RIGHT NOW AND THAT
WE'LL DEFLECT IT TO SAVE
HUMANITY.
BRUCE WILLIS STYLE.
NO, IT IS A TEST.
>> THAT WOULD BE A SLIGHTLY
BIGGER STORY TODAY IF WE WERE
INDEED TRYING TO SAVE HUMANITY
FROM A KILLER ASTROID.
>> YOU THINK?
>> I WOULD HOPE SO.
I CAN'T PROMISE YOU THAT, BUT I
WOULD HOPE SO.
LET ME MOVE TO ARTEMIS BECAUSE
I'M STARTING TO WONDER WHETHER
OR NOT THIS MISSION, YOU KNOW,
WAS BORN UNDER A BAD SIGN OR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
THE THIRD LAUNCH ATTEMPT OF
ARTEMIS 1 WAS SET FOR TUESDAY,
BUT NASA HAS SINCE CALLED IT OFF
BECAUSE OF HURRICANE IAN, WHICH
OBVIOUSLY MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
NASA WILL EVALUATE WHETHER TO
ROLL BACK THE SPACE LAUNCH
SYSTEM TO THE KENNEDY SPACE
CENTER.
ARE YOU FRUSTRATED BY THIS, I
GUESS THEY ARE SHOWING THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF CAUTION.
AND WHY DO YOU THINK THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT THIS MISSION?
>> SO A COUPLE THINGS.
FIRST, IT HAS BEEN 50 YEARS
SINCE WE'VE LAST BEEN TO THE
MOON.
SO I CAN WAIT A FEW WEEKS.
THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM.
AND I'M GLAD THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH
DATA ON THE LAUNCH SPECS TO KNOW
WHEN TO SCRUB A MISSION AND
DELAY IT AND WHEN NOT TO.
AND OF COURSE A HURRICANE,
FLORIDA IS NO STRANGER TO
HURRICANES, SO THIS IS JUST
ANOTHER -- YOU KNOW, OF COURSE,
YOU WILL DELAY IT.
AND BY THE WAY, THERE ARE NO
ASTRONAUTS ON THIS MISSION TO
THE MOON.
IT IS BASICALLY A TEST WHAT HAVE
IS NOW THE MOST POWERFUL ROCKET
ON EARTH.
AND IN CASE PEOPLE DIDN'T KNOW,
THIS ARTEMIS PROGRAM, ARTEMIS IS
THE TWIN SISTER OF APOLLO.
SO THAT WAS A CLASSY THING DO I
THOUGHT THERE JUST AS A REMINDER
THAT THERE ARE MORE GENDERS IN
THE WORLD THAN MEN WITH CREW
CUTS WHO SOUND LIKE MISSION
CONTROL.
A WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE WE CAN
SEND INTO SPACE.
AND I THINK THERE IS ANOTHER ONE
THAT IS ALSO UNCREWED, AND I
THINK THAT IT IS THE THIRD ONE
THAT WILL HAVE A CREW THAT WILL
GO.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
THIS.
IT HAS BEEN A WHILE.
>> I GUESS I'M JUST IMPATIENT, I
WANT TO SEE IT HAPPEN.
BUT OF COURSE WE HAVE TO DO
SAFELY.
AND I'VE BEEN WANTING TO GET
YOUR TAKE ABOUT THE WEBB
TELESCOPE AND THESE INCREDIBLE
IMAGES COMING IN, I WONDER WHAT
YOU THINK OF THEM BECAUSE YOU'VE
BEEN STUDYING THIS FOR SO LONG.
AND I GUESS DOES THIS BLOW YOU
AWAY?
I MEAN, THIS WEEK WE GOT THESE
IMAGES OF NEPTUNE AND ITS RINGS.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME RINGS
HAVE BEEN SEEN IN INFRARED.
ARE YOU JUST -- AGAIN, ARE YOU
JUST BLOWN AWAY BY THIS, DO YOU
GET BLOWN AWAY BY ANYTHING AND
IS THIS ONE OF THOSE THINGS?
>> WE SHOULD ALL GET OUR MINDS
BLOWN AT LEAST ONCE A DAY.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS, THAT THERE
ARE SO MANY CONTINGENT THINGS
THAT HAD TO WORK TO GET THE WEBB
TELESCOPE OUT THERE IS A MILLION
MILES FROM EARTH.
THIS THING WAS FOLDED UP INTO
THE FARING OF THE ROCKET BECAUSE
WE SAID HOW DO WE GET A
TELESCOPE BIGGER THAN THE SIZE
OF THE FARING ITSELF.
AND AN ENGINEER SAID WE HAVE AN
IDEA, LET'S CREATE A FOLDABLE
ROCKET.
MORE LIKE THE PETALS OF A
FLOWER, RIGHT?
AND THEY FOLD IT UP, SEND IT OUT
UNFURL IT, AND THERE IT IS
PARKED A MILLION MILES AWAY FROM
EARTH OPPOSITE THE SUN AND
EVERYTHING WORKED AS PLANNED.
AND SO I THINK WE'RE ALL SHOCKED
THAT IT MET THE SPECS TO EXACTLY
WHAT WE WANTED TO DO AND THAT
WAS ENOUGH TO JUST FREAK US ALL
OUT.
THE HIGH RESOLUTION, THE FACT
THAT IT IS A BANDWIDTH THAT LETS
YOU SEE THINGS DIFFERENTLY, THAT
IMAGE OF NEPTUNE, THAT IS WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE IF WE HAD INFRARED
EYEBALLS.
SO THIS IDEA THAT EVERYTHING
THAT IS THE WORLD, THAT THE
WORLD IS OR SHOULD BE IS VISIBLE
TO OUR EYES, WE'VE KNOWN AS
ASTROPHYSICISTS LONG AGO THAT SO
MANY OF THE UNIVERSE IS
HAPPENING AND COMES TO US IN
BANDS OF LIGHT THAT ARE OUTSIDE
THE VISIBLE SPECTRUM.
AND THAT IS WHY YOU NEED
TELESCOPES AND DETECTORS AND
ENGINEERS RIGHT ALONGSIDE TO
HELP US MAKE THOSE MEASUREMENTS.
>> YEAH, GADGETS AND GIZMOS ARE
IMPORTANT.
AND BEFORE I LET YOU GO, I HAVE
TO GET YOUR REACTION TO THE U.S.
SPACE FORCE'S ORIGINAL SONG THAT
WAS RELEASED THIS WEEK.
LET'S PLAY A SNIPPET AND GET
YOUR THOUGHTS.
♪ INTO SPACE THERE IS AN IMAGE
IN THE SKY SENDING NIGHT AND DAY
THE SPACE FORCE ♪
>> ACTUALLY, THAT IS THE FIRST
I'VE HEARD IT, BUT IT SOUNDS
VERY 1950s, YOU KNOW.
KIND OF LIKE WHAT YOU'D SING
WHEN THE CHANNELS WENT OFF THE
AIR AT MIDNIGHT.
BUT I KIND OF LIKE IT.
>> I KIND OF LIKE IT TOO.
AND, YOU KNOW, I GUESS FOLKS
MIGHT BE IN THIS AGE OF TROLLING
AND SO ON SOCIAL MEDIA, FOLKS
MIGHT BE TEMPTED TO TAKE A SHOT
AT IT, BUT I THINK IT SOUNDS
VERY PATRIOTIC AND THERE ARE
SOME REALLY GREAT PEOPLE WHO
WORK AT THE SPACE FORCE, FLIGHT
SO WHY NOT HAVE A FIGHT SONG.
WILL THEY HAVE A FOOTBALL TEAM,
THAT IS THE QUESTION THAT I
HAVE.
>> AND WHAT IS FUNNY, OR
CURIOUS, IS THAT THE OTHER
BRANCHES OF THE ARMED FORCES
SONGS TEND TO BE SONGS THAT YOU
WOULD MARCH TO.
YOU FEEL THAT URGE TO GET UP AND
MARCH.
BUT SPACE FORCE, YOU WANT TO BE
ABLE TO FEEL LIKE YOU WANT TO
LAUNCH SOMETHING.
AND I DIDN'T FEEL LAUNCHY WITH
THOSE LYRICS OR WITH THE
RHYTHMS, BUT MAYBE IF YOU WATCH
A ROCKET LAUNCH WHILE YOU HEAR
IT, THAT WILL RESET HOW WE THINK
ABOUT THE MOOD WE SHOULD ATTAIN
AS WE LISTEN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND WE'RE PLAYING THE MUSIC
RIGHT NOW AS YOU ARE SPEAKING.
AND WHAT YOU ARE SAYING SOUNDS
SO MUCH BETTER WITH THAT MUSIC
PLAYING BEHIND YOU.
SO THERE MUST BE SOMETHING TO
IT.
>> I TOLD YOU.
>> NEIL deGRASSE TYSON, THANKS
FOR INDULGING ME HAVING A LITTLE
FUN THIS AFTERNOON A.
APPRECIATE IT.
AND MY MIND HAS BEEN BLOWN.
THANKS SO MUCH.A.
APPRECIATE IT.
AND MY MIND HAS BEEN BLOWN.
THANKS SO MUCH..
APPRECIATE IT.
AND MY MIND HAS BEEN BLOWN.
THANKS SO MUCH.
CHECK OUT HIS NEW BOOK